hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast understanding cancer cell
matrix interactions and the 3d cell
migration presented by Nicholas corneal
on PhD assistant professor in the
department of biomedical engineering at
eindhoven university of technology we
are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by bit plain bit
claim is the world leading interactive
microscopy image analysis software
company known for amorous which is
actively shaping the way microscopic
images are processed through constant
innovation and a clear focus on 3-d and
4-d imaging analysis and data
exploration to learn more about bit
plane please visit www believe com
today's webinar is a part of the search
series where bit plane invites
researchers from the top scientific and
medical institutions who have dedicated
their work to discover new therapeutic
agents or vaccines for some of the most
severe diseases of the 21st century they
are delighted to discover that in many
cases Mars has pushed the research
forward putting the scientists closer to
finding new therapy I am Judy O'Rourke
of lab roots and I'll be your moderator
for today's event before we begin I'd
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation this
presentation has been approved for
continuing educational credits if you
want to obtain the credit please click
on the get your free cm ECE credits
button located in the lower left of your
screen it will take you through the
process to obtain your certification
also please notice that you'll be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge the window just click
on the screen icon located on the lower
right and finally if you have trouble
skiing or sharing the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button to let us know
that you're having a problem thank you
now I'd like to introduce Nicholas
corneal once he received his PhD and
2012 from the National University of
Singapore studying the role of matrix
matrix visco elasticity in cancer
metastases event carried out his
postdoctoral research as a Marie Curie
fellow in home Institute almost
Amsterdam in the Netherlands
investigating the hierarchical structure
property relations in the cytoskeleton
and extracellular matrices his works
have provided important insights into
the underlying physical mechanism behind
the intriguing nonlinear behaviour of
protein network in 2015 he joined
Eindhoven University of Technology in
eindhoven the netherlands as an
assistant professor in the biomedical
engineering department combining his
expertise on biopolymers physics cell
bio mechanics and cytoskeletal rheology
is currently search focuses on the
biophysical and makenna biological
aspects of cell matrix interactions and
the applications in regenerative
medicine please join me in welcoming
Nicholas Kearney l1 I will now turn your
presentation over to him all right
thanks Judy for the introduction it's a
pleasure to be here and speaking to you
guys today and for that all thanked
first of all the people from bit plain
and lap roots for making this event
happen and for bringing us together
today for this presentation so yeah so
I'm going to talk about some matrix
interactions um today and in particular
how the interactions between the cells
and the matrix affect the way that cells
migrate in three-dimensional environment
especially in the context of cancer so
so the the primary research interest in
my group is biology
in physical context so biology in
context by in particular in the physical
contracts of cell behavior so basically
the primary questions that we are trying
to answer is how our biological
functions are the cell and tissue levels
affected by the material properties of
the selected tissues so so I think in
this particular case cancer is a
particularly good example a prime
example of health Omnitrix interactions
can really affect or even influence
dramatically influence he'll sell
behaved so well yeah probably you all
know about cancer I think yeah everyone
knows what cancer and this has been sort
of depicted very very nicely by
Siddhartha Mukherjee in his pulitzer
prize-winning book say in 2010 yeah so
the book was written before 2010 so in
2010 about 600,000 Americans and more
than 7 million humans run the world will
die of cancer in that states one in
three women and one in two men both of
all cancer during the last time a
quarter of all american deaths and about
fifteen percent of all deaths worldwide
will be attributed to cancer in some
nations canceled or surpassed heart
disease to become the most common cause
of death so it's obvious that you know
cancer is a big business is a big threat
of humankind so what are really the
characteristic of cancer that you know
makes it so devastating so in in in 270
papers by Hannah Hannah and Weinberg
they sort of summarized the the six or
even eat hallmarks of cancer so it's
shown in this slide so basically the
cells can sustain proliferative
signaling meaning that they can
basically and defied and continue to
fight much more than normal cells to
they can resist cell death the faith
groups oppressors and so on and so forth
and but what I think is most important
is actually this right here activating
invasion and metastasis so in fact right
so in fact metastasis is responsible for
ninety percent of solid tumor related
deaths so what that means is if if you
or somebody or a patient has cancer or
tumor but the tumor is isolated is
localized and it's not invading any
other organ or tissue then chances are
you'll the patient will will be fine
will be up yeah we can we can remove
that the tissue containing the tumor and
then it's there will be no other or no
further proliferation of cancer cells
but once the cancer cells have been
faded other tissues and metastasize then
yeah he's in a big trouble so what is
really happening during metastasis so
what's happening is you have this
primary tumor some cells are able to get
out of this probably tumor migrate to
the tissue getting the blood flow stream
and then circulate throughout our body
find a greener pasture somewhere migrate
again and start a new colony so there is
a huge multi-step multistage process
going on and the cells have to migrate
to a very very different or diverse kind
of tissue so they have to migrate over
here so for example this could be a
breast tissue and get into the
bloodstream move the better in the blood
circulation and migrate again to a very
very potentially very different kind of
tissue and then start a new colony
so really the cells are subjected to or
they are exposed to many different kind
of tissues with very different or
diverse microstructure and they need to
be able to migrate through it and
survive and also proliferate and this is
particularly interesting because there
are many ways that the cells can migrate
so I'm showing three examples here so
the center example is basically a
household's migrating in a wound healing
a see the right example is health cells
are able to collectively migrate or move
as a colony in what if storm collectives
on migration what is happening on the
last video is individual cell migrating
or moving following chemoattractants so
the this pipettes kind of thing is
actually providing chemo traction for
the cell result is able to sense that
and migrate towards the source of the
kimmel attractant and so coming back to
the metastasis process so I said before
that in metastasis the cells have to
migrate through very very potentially
very very different tissues with very
very diverse microstructure so see if
you can imagine if you have a cell
migrating through breast tissue and then
it has to go to it it finds a greener
pasture in a boon and tries to migrate
in a boon the cell will experience or
feel or sense very very different
environment or substrate and this has
been studied very elegantly in this
paper by Lou it all in 2000 so what they
do is they plead self on a substrate
adjust to these substrate
and so half of a substrate is soft and
helps the other health of the substrate
is stiff and apparently Ln the set of a
monitor where the sauce how the cells
might be anywhere dissolves migrate and
apparently the cells that started out on
the loss on the soft side of the
substrate for example did so they can
hit the the interface of the softest
interface substrates interface and
happily move over to the state substrate
whereas if the cells start from the
stiffs substrate that was stiff half of
the substrate they hit the interface and
they basically decide not to go into it
so there seems to be a preferential
stiffness of the substrate for the self
and yeah finally the cells behave
differently the morphology of the cell
is different in soft and stiff substrate
and coming back to the idea of
metastasis different tissues in our body
apparently have a very very tight
diverse mechanical properties for
example brain as elasticity off on the
order of 0.1 21 kiloPascals butt muscles
for example has about ten to a hundred
times stiffer mechanical properties
about ten kilo Pascal's Bulls obviously
is a lot more stiff so self really have
to migrate through very different
substrates with very different
mechanical properties and so and people
start to look at how cells are able to
achieve that how cells are able to
migrate through all these different
tissues with different mechanical
properties so the two experimental
athletes that people have used so far in
studying 3d cell migration is so either
deep put self randomly in the matrix
basically just on spread the sauce
everywhere in the metric matrix and let
them set up microwave in a random
manner and then monitor the migration
properties of these cells or they create
steroids of cells basically a colony of
self and they look at how cells are able
to invade to matrix the surrounding
matrix from this colony themselves so
these are you know very simple in
feature oh I see it provides great
statistics you can monitor hundreds of
cells at one experiment fancy but
varying matrix properties is typically
not straightforward because the cells
are in the matrix from the very
beginning so our idea with something
like this where you have cells in what
we call inner gel so this is the inner
gel we use college in chelsea in our
collagen gel and we sort of encapsulate
this inner gel in an outer shell without
any cell so the idea is we will let the
cells migrate out from the inner gel to
the outer shell and monitor how the
cells are migrating to the outer shell
and if you are interested in in the
details the experimental details feel
free to look at this paper where we
describe in a video protocol hell the
essay setup so this of this is all so
simple it mimics tumult apology it has
quickly provide career statistics and
importantly varying matrix probably is
straightforward because all you need to
do is basically change the properties of
the outer shell without doing anything
to the inner gel so the experimental
model is something like this you have a
two primary site at a center in the
inner gel and then we left the cells
migrate out into the outer shell and
then we look at how the cells migrate
through the outer job and this is
our experience with email is the server
immerse provided by bit plane has been
very good so immersive is able to track
many many cells simultaneously and not
in 3d but also in 42 3d plus time so I
mentioned the ability to change very
easily the properties of the matrix and
study how cells are able to migrate in
different kind of matrix so we did that
and what I'm plotting here for example
is the speed of the cell migration and
the histogram the speed of the cell
migration in different matrices so for
example these are basically collagen
gels of different densities 1.5 to 154
mix for mill and these are present gels
with the same density but with different
ph polymerization ph i will get back to
this why we do this kind of variations
in a couple of slides but that's not the
only thing that we get out so the
readout is the Selfridge Ector II and we
can quantify it for example cell speed
but also what we call a persistence so
how soon the cell is in the migration of
the ejector II and so one of the
findings that we found was very
interesting if is this so if you
actually think of migrating cells micro
self migrating in the population and you
think of it as migrating wave a wave of
migrating population you can sort of
categorize themselves within the
population as themselves right in front
of the population right the migration
from physically or the cells behind them
the cells that are what we call in the
migration region and what we found was
very interesting is apparently the speed
the speed of the cells in the migration
front is higher
typically higher than the speed of the
cells behind them so we are seeing in
the gray bars here is the histogram the
self at the migration front and which is
significantly higher than the cells
behind them two black bars but not only
that but apparently directionality is
also very different so if you qualify
the persistence of the trajectory a
brownie the self at the front move with
a lot more directionality so in this
example I'm plotting a result a sample
where I'm looking at this particular
spot in the sample so the cells are
predominantly moving to the left whereas
themselves behind them are migrating
sort of more randomly so at the same
time we are also looking at what is
happening to the matrix what is having
to the matrix surrounding the cells the
fiber networks surrounding the cells and
and obviously people have noted
previously that the cells are able to do
many things to the fibers running them
they said the cells can pull on the
fibers they can push the fibers away
they can for example to create the
matrix the creative fibers if if they
are sort of trapped in a very dense
matrix local matrix they can deposit
matrix so there are many remodeling by
the cell on the matrix both physically
and chemically so having this in mind we
hypothesize or we sort of speculated
that what we were seeing previously was
kind of a terrain effect so what I mean
by that is the self at on my bridge in
front what what they have in front of
them is really a very very nice forest
you know matrix or fiber networks which
are pristine untouched by other cells
they moved halfway through it
and they might create very quickly and
with a lot of directionality whereas the
cells behind them what they have in
front of them is really something like
this a force that has been cut down by
cells behind up in front of them with a
lot of mechanical and biochemical cues
around them and basically the cells get
confused there are too many queues
everywhere and that sort of impedes the
directionality of the of the cells and
that's why the cells move slower and
with a lot more randomness in the
migration region so that's not the only
thing that we did so we started to yeah
mess with a wheel so we we start to mess
with the molecular mechanisms that allow
for cell migration so for example we
added drugs that affect for example my
connectivity or affecting polymerization
or mechanical stability or even on drugs
that inhibit the ability of this also
decrease matrix oh mmv inhibitor and so
this is the result in terms of what is
the change in cell speed so Delta s is
the change in speed and delta k is a
change in cell persistence and in most
of the cases the drug produced the drugs
produced a negative value for the speed
meaning that the cells are less able to
microwave this oh well the cells migrate
with a much reduced speed but the extent
of the efficacy of these drugs are
different so in this particular example
cytokeratin d which affects the
polymerizations of actin affecting is a
lot more effective in terms of reducing
sail speed but not in terms of reducing
cell persistence
but but that's not the only thing so we
also started to do all this drug studies
in different matrices so all this bar
graphs are actually showing the for
example chains of self speed and chains
of some persistence in the different
matrices 2.5 miles per mil 1.54 so
towards the left or right is basically
increasing calls intensity and towards
the bottom is increasing pore size so
basically the ph of the parameterization
piece of the collagen gel influences the
pore size of the gel without affecting
the without changing the constant
density so ph9 produced jose with very
small force on the order of 1 microns
and if you go up to if you put down to
peers of six then you end up with a
shell up for example I think it's about
five microns even with the same constant
density so now you can start to sculpt
this in for all this information from
this bar graphs and we certainly have
spent many hours trying to analyze this
and understand what is going on but the
main message that I'm going to discuss
the day in this presentation is that you
know the all the bars look different and
when all the VARs look different that
means that some drugs are more effective
than other drugs in some museum some
interest and some drugs are more
effective than in one matrix than in
other matrices so that means that there
is no sort of universal drug new best
rock and there's no Universal matrix and
that the cells adapt so that means that
if you want to come up with a drug that
impede or inhibit cancer cell migrations
then you need to be able to test the
effect
self-destruct in in a context at in the
proper context where the drug is going
to be applied so in for example you want
to look at the efficiency of district 2
of the potency of this truck tool for
example inhibit cancer cell migrations
in fairy dense matrices then you need to
test this in very dense matrices and not
very porous matrix and our PI supercell
course so what have you learned so far
so we've learned that yeah so we've came
up with a very simple yet powerful in
theatre study in theatre experimental
setup to study 3d solving equations
quantitatively we've known that
individual cell migration is strongly
affected by biophysical and also the
structural properties of the local my
friend apartment not just a bulk
environment and mechanic elasticity
allows cells to actively adept and this
is the keyword the cells can adapt their
invasion machinery depending on the
matrix what they are having is running
them so all of this are you know
pointing us towards the matrix so it is
important to look at what happens at the
matrix in how the cells are able to
interact with the matrix both physically
and chemically you know so people have
been trying to understand cell behavior
and how they respond to for example by
kanaka and mechanical stimuli but the
sort of thing of it as a black box but
in reality this also are also able to
change the environment they can also
send back by chemical mechanical similar
to the environment of the matrix which
can then be sensed by other cells so in
essence what I'm saying is that no man
is an island no cell is an island so
cells are never alone in the body but
most studies were done on isolated cells
so there
is coming up kind of a mishmash your
conceptual mismatch and the environment
and the interactions between the selling
that environment need to be considered
so I think yeah coming back to the the
my my first light so we are interested
in biology in the physical context and I
think this is very very beautifully
captured in the two feeders and i'm
showing here so these are videos
captured by the group of eric patrick so
what I'm showing on the Left video is
basically a cell oh well a couple of
cells migrating and what you're saying
what you're seeing in the cells the
colorful filaments in the cells those
are the cytoskeleton so this other
skeletons are very dynamic and
remodeling all the time ssl cells are
actively migrating but that's not the
only picture the only issue or thing
that we need to consider but outside of
the cell you also have this fibrous
network so this is just the green thing
is the SL migrating to my dream within a
collagen matrix so I also notice all
there's also this protein networks and
these brilliant networks are dynamically
remodeled by the cells so the question
then is what is the cell feel if they're
in this kind of protein networks what do
they feel how can we know what this
sense and how they interact with this
environment so so I guess the the most
straight for answer well way to answer
this question is to try to feel what the
southfield and you know people have been
trying to correct rice mechanically the
infirmary liam matrix and also by for
you know protein networks and by polymer
networks using a bulk measurement like
mccrory ology so what happens is you
you have a plate and another plate or a
cone and you put assembles in between
and you applying kind of a twisting
motion or sharing motion and you look at
the stress and strain and you deduce
what is the mechanical properties of the
matrix but that is a bulk measurement
and that is probably not what this also
are feeling so we need another approach
which can measure local properties
properties that the cells can sense for
themselves and one way to do that is
using what is called micro radiology so
what a 70 and microbiology is instead of
measuring the entire sample in bulk you
put a probe inside the sample or the
matrix so from in this case is just a
microsphere or beat and you put them in
put these bits in the matrix and by
looking at the particle dynamics thought
that how the beach move due to Brownian
motion in this matrix or the sample you
can deduce things like microstructure
the microstructure of the matrix and the
local mechanical compliance because what
the probe is probing that what the beat
is probing in this particular case is
just a farrier local environmental
fairly local matrix is not the entire
sample so this way you can really
measure the mechanical properties at
local scale micro scale so this is not a
not a new idea people have been doing
this for several years and people have
in fact put beads or probes in the cell
inside of the cells and looking at the
particle dynamics of the probes in the
cells they can look at it they can sort
of measure the local viscoelasticity
within themselves within the cytoplasm
but what we are trying to do is look at
measure
what the cell is feeling so basically if
this is a cell we want to know what the
cell is feeling over here we want to
know how stiff this particular region is
healthy if this particular region is and
so on and so forth so that's basically
what we did so we put beads in in the
matrix surrounding yourself and looking
at the Brownian motion of these beats we
can calculate for example the elastic
moduli and the loss modulus of the local
matrix so in this particular example i'm
showing you this is a cell and well i
mean this is the leading edge of the
cell and those small dots are basically
our probes so these are our probes and
so these are in front of the leading
edge of the cell and we also put probes
around the cell body so for example
peace and based on the motion based on
the motions of these beads we can
calculate the elastic modulus and the
loss modulus and what we are seeing is
apparently the region in front of the
cell have significantly higher loss
modulus competitor so this is in front
of the leading edge of the cell and this
is around cell body and basically the
the elastic modulus or the stiffness of
the local matrix doubles when the cells
are sort of doing something on the
matrix so by looking at the same time at
what the matrix is doing we we are able
to see that in front of the matrix in
front row leading edge of the matrix
there's a lot of bundling of the fibers
saying this case calls and fibers so
that when basically that means is that
the cells are able to grab onto cousin
fibers and pull these fibers just
because Excel contractility and pull
fibers towards them and thereby creating
bundles thick bundles of causing fibers
and that is what is causing this
increase in stiffness locally in front
of the matrix so basically itself can
exert contractile forces to establish
themselves and this forces change the
local probability of the matrix the
discourses make the local nature's
dipper and well if ya so you can think
of it this way if you put a cell in the
matrix they do this kind of conductivity
and they create this kind of small
pockets of higher local stiffnesses so
you can hypothesize that if you put more
and more cells there will be a lot more
of these pockets of high stiffness so
the hypothesis then is if you put more
and more self the tissue the entire
tissue or matrix will become stiffer and
that is something that we can test and
apparently of that is that is indeed the
case so if you put more and more cells
the stiffness the stiffness of the
metric goes up significantly but if you
for example inhibit contractility of the
cell by adding drugs or whatever then
you do not see that so this asteroid
symbols are the control measurements
where contractility is inhibited so that
means that this accumulation of this
local stiffening due to sell lead to a
large-scale macroscale tj's Tiffany but
that's actually not the entire story so
I mean I'm telling you what happens in
proximal cause and cells or other
biopolymer just like fibrin shelf but so
people start to do this in different
kind of licenses and in this particular
study for example they would self in
pack hydrogel so packed
these hydrogels with you know Archie do
what if I compacts and we saw with some
ability so they put our GD peptides on
the pack and also peptides that that are
able to be degraded by the matrix so
base by the by the self so when they put
self in there and the pore size of this
kind of peg hydrogels is very very tiny
in the order of nano meters there the
cells are basically initially stuck in a
matrix but they're able to decrease
running matrix and thereby they are able
to move around and this kind of
experiment shows that when they did
micro reality around the cells the area
the local regions running the cells are
actually more liquidy more viscous than
it is elastic and this especially the
the parish shallower area they become a
lot more liquidy whereas the area you
know far from the cells they are still
kind of a elastic solids so what this
study and our study show is that
depending on the kind of matrix that the
cells find themselves in they can do
different kind of modification or
remodeling of the local matrix around
them so so yeah without all this
computer our presentation today and yeah
so the conclusion is actually you know
context context context context is super
important if you're trying to understand
the cell behavior in physiologically
relevant situations and of course by
context what I mean is some interesting
interactions so we need to be able to
understand what kind of interactions to
sell are able to do with the matrix
inhale this interactions are
isolated and manifested in terms of the
mechanical local mechanical properties
as well as structural properties but
what I say what I've described in this
presentation is just you know sort of
scratching the surface so I've described
a little bit about the physical and
mechanical aspect of cell matrix
interactions but in a reality in our
body for example the interestingly in
the cell in the matrix takes place in in
a very very complex way involving many
many different factors both physical or
mechanical and biochemical and all of
these factors are you know they are
affecting each other in ways that we are
still trying to understand so all these
arrows show you what people have shown
to be you know sort of fact factors that
are affecting each other in in terms of
self-interest interactions and so the
cell metric conversion itself is also
quite dynamic is changing as a function
of time and so the matrix can affect our
behavior at the same times the cells can
affect or can change the matrix
properties and this feedback loop
between the sound of matrix are still
you know this kind of feedback loops
needs still to be investigated further
and this is particularly important in
that in a case of tumor and of course I
haven't really dealt much into tumor you
know my free environment by intamin
microenvironment there's a lot of
infectious not only between the cellular
matrix but also between different kind
of cells different cell types and I
think what will be very beneficial in
the future and so this is what I
confusion will be
the the way forward in terms of
understanding cell behavior but also in
terms of cancer understanding cancer my
invasion and cancer progression and also
you know trying to develop therapeutic
all preventable interventions in cancer
but also in things like tissue
engineering where the interaction of
physical and mechanical and by chemical
interaction with the cell matrix are
very important in terms of for example
things are creating designing scaffolds
with design property with desired
properties to direct cell behavior so
what I think will be the very important
in the future is how we can integrate
all this information so you know so the
cell phenotype is basically going to be
a function of internal state of the cell
ya rabbi chemical regulation within
itself and also self our communication
but at the same time how the cells are
able to interact with a matrix and how
the cells are able to sense the physical
by chemical mechanical signals from the
matrix how the cells are able to change
these cues the physical by chemical
mechanical cues in the matrix and how
this are all integrated together to to
cell phenotype so with that I'll
actually in the presentation and I will
thank the people that have contributed
to my work so people in hind joven
people in singapore MIT alliance who
have been working with me on the micro
biology as well as the people in
national university of singapore but
also the people in the canna biology
Institute especially on cancer
metastasis studies and I will
also the funding agencies that have
provided the financial support for my
work and so thanks all for listening and
I think we have a bit of a time now for
question and answer so feel free to send
in your questions and I'll be happy to
answer it thank you dr. crane Yellin for
that informative presentation it's time
for Q&A if you have a question you'd
like to ask our speaker please do so now
just click on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen and click on
the send button while answer as many of
your questions as we have time for let's
get started our first question is if
self have trouble in migration in soft
substrate how can invasion assays and
hydrogels and other soft matrices be
compared to physiological invasion okay
so yes if if cells have trouble in
migration in soft substrate how can
invasion assays in hydrogels and other
soft matrices be compared to
physiological invasion so I'm not sure I
understand the question so the cells do
not typically have trouble migration and
migrating in soft substrates oh so I
think uh yeah so probably this person is
asking about the 2d essay that I
described in the fair beginning where
the cells are able to microwave from
this office substrate but not the other
way around so that actually doesn't mean
that the cells are not able to migrate
on soft substrate so they are able to
migrate um yeah just fine but they have
some preference to migrate to be or not
just migrated but to a deer on and be on
stiffer substrates but to directly
answer this question
so in our asses the the experimental
assets are actually in treaty which are
you know it is a very different
environment compared to 2d so the cells
are actually in the matrix it is
probably the stiffness of the matrix in
this 3d environment 3d matrix is not
going to be directly comparable to the
stiffness or going to be on the
stiffness readout that you get from 2d
substrates so it's on the other fusilli
between you know you know on the other
of 10 and 100 Pascal's and in terms of
sharing young's moduli and the cells do
not have any trouble my breeding in this
kind of matrices so in fact if you
compare this kind of stiffness to the
stiffness of tissues in human body and
physiology then it's comparable for
example to tissues in breast issues both
in terms of microstructure and
mechanical properties so I hope I've
answered this question how do you create
inner and outer gels technically do you
have a special 3d chamber or alright
yeah so yes I said before for more
technical information inhale the the
assays done in setup you can obviously
look into our journal of visualize
experiment paper where there is actually
a video a very very informative video
where this is done in how it is set up
but basically what we did was we create
a kind of a dome-shaped inner gel so
what I drew as a diagram it was kind of
a little bit deceiving so it's not
really cylindrical kind of shape gel
energy gel but it's kind of a
dome-shaped gel and the entire inner gel
with the sauce inside there are sort of
encapsulated in rule basically we added
the second layer of gel the outer shell
on top of it and surrounding it so in
practice it's very easily is just a
matter of putting one Sean
or surrounding each other for this next
one I don't know the name of the journal
florell just yet which sells did you use
in your 2015 JV exp publication right
yeah so so far we've been focusing on
cancer cells so we've been looking at
you know breast cancer cells like md mba
231 but also felt like mcf10a mcf-7 this
kind of cell types just migration
through collagen gels change between
cells can you repeat a bridge sure does
the migration through collagen gels
change between cell oh right yeah so of
course different cell types have
different migration characteristics you
know you know some some cells are just
migrating faster than others some cell
service you know have a tendency to sort
of walk or microwave slowly but
qualitatively we are seeing sort of
similar behavior so what I described
before in terms of you know the selfie
the migration fun and themselves behind
them and how the characterization of the
migration of these two types of cells
are very different we see them in most
of the cell lines that we have been
studying have you tried to generate
these hydrogels in a high-throughput for
high-throughput screening that's a great
question so the answer is no so um yeah
probably there is something that we have
to look more into the future is it
possible second is it possible to do the
3d culture in a high-throughput way for
example to use in the small molecule
screening or si RNA in all likelihood
yes so so so far we've been the extron
of the assay that we have been working
on is kind of
not a very high throughput in terms of
the matrix so in terms of the cell it is
very high throughput because in in one
experiment or in one essay we can
monitor the migration behavior of
hundreds many hundreds of self in one
experiment but in terms of you know
looking at not only self with you know
as RNA interference but also self
different types of self and different
disease states for example it hasn't
been high throughput so we only have one
or a few assays for studying one cell
types and you probably need multiple of
this series of experiments to do that
but in the future I can foresee that
this kind of essay can be made high
throughput by miniaturizing so you
probably don't have to create inner and
outer gels with with the dimensions that
we've been working with so far so so
we've been working with audio off like
17 or 18 millimeter gels probably it's
not necessary to go that big so in first
of all this can be made smaller and in a
way that allows you to look at multiple
cell types and you know states of the
self in in a more robust and hydro good
way how do you analyze this data ok so
I'm not sure which data your
questionnaire is asking about we did not
specify this year so let's listen you
watchin expiration what is the actual
method by which you measure this
microbiology is it a computer
Mike monitored process of particle
Brownian motion can this be used for 2d
applications would you like to answer
those separately just one at a time what
is the actual method by which you
measure you might go right I can try to
answer this very quickly so um yeah so
what we did was we basically look at we
took video part of video you know just
videos of beets beet movement in discuss
matrices and the analysis of the Beat
movement is done offline so it's not
really an online measurement so you do
the offline measurement by looking at
the trajectory of this beach and using
generalized Stokes Einstein equation you
can back help with or not back out the
source and loss module I for to the
application it is possible of course you
have to worry about for example if you
put the bead on a surface for example
then probably the motion is going to be
affected by you know things like
friction with the surface and looks like
that but otherwise if the environment is
isotropic so that means that there is no
difference between the motion of the
beat in XY or separations then just
looking at the 2d movement of the
particles can already tell you something
about the 3d local properties in which
microscopy set up did you use for
imaging the cell migration from inner
gel to outer gel right so we use our
confocal set up with equipped with a
cell culture chamber so what we did was
we look at some what we call volumes of
interest within the outer shell and we
will look at several volumes of interest
and we look at we took 3d images as a
function of time of these volumes of
interest and by a look by looking at the
of and tracking the cells within this
volume self-interest and in this
particular case we are using Emery's the
email software we were able to track the
movement of the cells for a long period
of time so we did up to a couple of
weeks of culture how did cells absorb
drugs in 3d gel matrix are the drugs
incubated in the gel that's right so we
basically put the drugs dissolve in the
medium and we put the mediums on top of
the gel so that the pore size of the
gels are large enough if you're on the
order of 1 to 10 microns that diffusion
of you know small molecule drugs within
the matrix is very very easy and very
very fast have you examined migration in
cocultures that's a great question and
that is again something that we need to
look into so far we haven't done that
what is the current direction on the
reason or ideas or on how the cells feel
let me start that one again what is the
current direction on the on the reason
or ideas on how the cells feels in their
environment how it translates on this
physical environment to a chemical
signal um yeah so of course um this is a
another great question and this impinges
on a very big field called
mechanotransduction so of course um
whatever the cell is filling on the
matrix on on the local environment is
going to be translated within the matrix
within the cell to by chemical signals
which then in turn is you know
influencing the decision making of the
cell itself and so in this presentation
I didn't have time to go into on you
know the details of hell meccano
transaction happens but there's a whole
lot of literature on that
I'm pretty sure that it's going to be
very easy to find some personal very few
articles on McKenna front section and
just some you know a picture of how
cells are able to translate mechanical
or physical signals from the environment
to by chemical signals within the self
and so the current direction or ideas is
yeah so this is a very big field right
now in emerging field and people are
still trying to understand what is going
on these measurements on individual
cells or cell population so we studied
the migration of individual cells within
a population so it's not really you know
cell colony so if you actually quantify
the sort of the average distance between
cells in the population is on the order
of five cell diameters so there's not
really a lot of self I'll contact going
on so we are really looking at
individual cell migration but within a
population if they're a minimal number
of cells that can be quantified well it
it really depends on what you're trying
to quantify what are you are trying to
study so I would say that it really
depends on you know for example things
like cell seeding density what is the
salsa intensity that you want to put in
and what you want to achieve in the end
so you can of course do the same kind of
a see where there's a lot of cell-cell
contact for example by just creating a
spirit or calling ourselves and looking
at you know things like hell cells are
able escape from this colony and migrate
into the environment but at the same
time by going for a very low self
feeding density recall i think as low as
about 50,000
sell for ml if I remember correctly and
that works fine so in that case you will
be seeing really you know individuals on
migrations we are almost out of time so
this will have to be our last question
what would be the difference in actin
dynamics between 2d and 3d migration
right so that is also an excellent
question so you know my great health
cells are able to migrate on 2d has been
very very well documented there is a
review for some about Boston burger and
and and and Alan horwitz and you know
the hell cells migrated onto the
surfaces the kind of actin dynamics onto
the surfaces is very very different from
the cell dynamics on treaty and in fact
this is something that we are currently
still looking at and so one of the
things that we are looking at right now
is what if what is the role of stress
fibers on to the to any healthy and 3d
environments so what I mean by to an
healthy environment is structures on
substrates that resembles 3d environment
that resembles fiber structures so we
are so looking at this you know what
kind of contractility health cells are
able to achieve contractility what kind
of forces they are able to exert on the
environment well weather or s vibrant
are as important in 3d as it is in 2d
what kind of you know focal adhesions
are important in these kind of
situations and so on and so forth so
this is really something that's so you
know being actively unstudied right now
I would like to once again to thank our
speaker for his presentation do you have
any final comments dr. Carney awan well
I would just like to thank everyone for
listening in this presentation I again
think the people from bits lean and lap
roots for organizing this event and so
feel free to just send us more questions
if you still have some questions and
I'll try to reply
questions as soon as I can thank you
thank you once again I would also like
to thank our sponsor bit plane for
making today's educational webcast
possible just reminder if you wish to
obtain the credits for today's session
please click on the get your free CME
credits button located in the lower left
of your screen this will take you
through the process to obtain your
certification before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing on
www plane calm forward slash search you
will receive an email from bit plane
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please sure that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live offense
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon goodbye